what is that
upstairs
[Music]
we're facing the greatest evil the world
has ever known
executing our people this is unlike
anything we've ever seen
[Music]
what's trying to kill us this time
pretty much everything
the magic is on a whole other level
we're outmatched
how are we gonna defeat them
I know what to do I can ask corpses five
questions and then they go back to being
dead
maybe I'm not saying it
yuck wonderful
were you killing battle yes great four
more questions right yes no no that
wasn't for you did that count as a
question yes damn it
only answer when I talk to you okay why
did you say Okay at the end of that I
didn't
fantastic where's the shovel